Do you know what is a heart attack?
Let us understand it.
Heart attack means "when a heart stops working".
How does it happen?
Let's see.
Sometimes, inside arteries, some sticky things get stuck to the walls,...
...and the way becomes blocked.
It's like a road where if there is some blockage, cars start coming back.
You are right!
When blood can't move further,...
...it starts coming back into the heart.
Also, the whole circulation of the blood stops.
So if the circulatory system does not work,...
...the heart can't get fresh oxygen.
You're a genius boy!
You are right!
When the circulatory system stops working, the heart can't get fresh oxygen.
And without fresh oxygen, it slowly, slowly dies.
Yes, sometimes it does not die fully.
Some part of it becomes inactive.
So when blood flow is restored,...
...the heart again gets oxygen and it again starts working.
You are right.
If blood circulation starts again, heart starts working again,...
...but it has become weak.
Yes, so you need to take some extra care.
So it does not get attacked again.